elle restera aussi celle des adieux de
lionel jospin ovationné à son départ de
matignon jeff wittamer
matignon elysées ce trajet là lionel
jospin lors a accompli au moins une fois
chaque semaine pendant cinq ans
aujourd'hui c'est la dernière
encore premier ministre pour quelques
instants il est accueilli sur les
marches de l'elysée par le secrétaire
général dominique de villepin mais un
quart d'heure plus tard les formalités
ont été brèves c'est le chef de l'état
en personne comme le veut la tradition
républicaine qui raccompagne lionel
jospin
la cohabitation s'achèvera sur cette
image
à matignon pendant ce temps c'est une
autre cérémonie qui se prépare la
passation des pouvoirs côté photographes
et caméras l'affluence des très grands
joueurs côté public le personnel de
matignon tout entier dans les rangs
serrés beaucoup de roses rouges
16 heures lionel jospin accueille son
successeur et il l'appelle d'emblée par
son nouveau
tout ira là aussi très vite moins de 20
minutes se sont écoulées lorsque lionel
jospin quitte définitivement matignon
sous les applaudissements
à ce moment beaucoup ont du mal à
retenir leur émotion on a passé beaucoup
de temps à s'écouter et voilà je retiens
la bruyère
je pense que le premier ministre était
aussi quelqu'un de bien et puis je pense
que les français le regretteront quant à
ses plus proches conseillers ils ont
paraît-il quitter un lionel jospin ce
sera ça n'était certainement pas une
posture c'est quelque chose qu'on a
ressenti profondément et qui je crois
nous a tous fait du bien corps dans des
tapis rouges sont remisés la cérémonie
s'achève un nouveau locataire s'est
installé à matignon